at the uh 2000
sydney paralympic games spain had to
return their gold medals after found out
their basketball team
nearly all their players were found to
have no disability
they just faked it
they were dominant yeah why are they in
wheelchairs
i think so so they're in wheelchairs
how did they find that i mean that's so
funny the guy goes in the locker room oh
guys i almost forgot to tell you they're
all standing up taking a shower
[Laughter]
hey why are y'alls wheelchairs not wet
like what do you mean well i mean
everybody else's wheelchair's wet
because take a shower in a wheelchair
but you guys are
you have them all parked outside your
locker room does that happen
the ipc
investigated the claims and found that
the required mental tests which should
show that the competitors have an iq of
no more than 75 so that's the cutoff
that's enough
to get be disabled uh
you could